des bases où la suite j'ai
appris dans ma sphère par les viscères
qu'on n'est pas là mais tout cas mais tu
as pas dessus mais qd à 32 ans
les mots sont pesant tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que le racisme ce n'est
pas bien
ainsi cette exposition du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de paris permet de
comprendre tous les mécanismes de la
construction de la haine de l'autre de
faire prendre conscience aux enfants du
cm1 jusqu'à au delà baccalauréat que le
pire et le meilleur
doivent lutter pour que le meilleur
gagne et que la souffrance
rappeler encore une fois par le poète
cesse d'exister et d'empêcher les hommes
et les femmes de vie faire venir cette
exposition est le fruit d'un travail
partenarial de longue date aux chiens
ces panneaux donnent des regards
multiples sur le mécanisme du racisme et
notre île comme le reste de la planète a
besoin de comprendre alors il s'agit pas
d'être pessimiste de considérer que nous
sommes racistes à la réunion mais il
faut être vigilant sur les dérives
parfois essentialisant tu ou
discriminante que nous pouvons mettre en
oeuvre notamment à l'égard par exemple
de minorités pain ou des derniers
arrivés mais ça vaut pour toutes les
toutes les identités ethniques en
réalité je sais pas je pense à
l'expression malbar 3b qui est
absolument insultante et infamantes ou
malbar y ait un lien ou il ya pu
chauffer tout ça c'est des expressions
qui sont courantes qui véhiculent des
préjugés et stéréotypes desquels il faut
apprendre à se prémunir
un chantier pertinent pour une
collectivité comme le département qui
gère notamment tous les collèges de
l'île est dans ce contexte qu vide
cette exposition ira à la rencontre du
public il y aura des formats de cette
exposition qui seront itinérante et qui
iront dans les collèges dans les écoles
vers les associations et permettre des
échanges sur le sujet permettent à ce
qui est des réflexions qui
prennent en compte donc toutes les
valeurs que nous prenons nous
préconisons les valeurs républicaines et
valeurs citoyennes et faire en sorte que
nous puissions aller au delà et avoir un
une façon plus libre de parler de ces
sujets de déconstruire pour reconstruire
mieux et avoir un mieux vivre ensemble
en toute liberté cette présentation
ouvre les festivités des journées du
patrimoine un peu particulière avec la
crise qu'ovide une situation difficile
qui nécessiterait peut-être de mieux
comprendre tous les éléments de contexte
qui alimentent notre cité et depuis je
me débats
merci
[Applaudissements]